everything everywhere all at once is a
film that comes along once in a lifetime
massively written edited and put
together it's one of my favorite movies
of all time already i'd heard about how
good it was from several people but
unfortunately due to its staggered
release schedule it didn't get released
in the uk until mid-may often i find
when films are hyped up like this that
they failed to deliver but not only did
this live up to my expectations it
completely surpassed them
[Music]
after re-watching it for a second time i
thought i'd go through while of the
movie some of the hidden things in it
you might have missed and also talk
about what i took from the ending if you
enjoy the video we'd massively
appreciate you hitting that thumbs up
button and also don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this
almost every day now throughout it we
follow evelyn a laundromat owner who's
not only struggling financially but also
with her family their husband weymond
has filed for divorce her father sees
her as a disappointment and evelyn
struggles to accept her daughter's
sexuality and also her girlfriend after
being called in by the irs her husband's
body gets possessed by someone claiming
to be from the alpha universe that wants
her to help him stop a great threat
known as the jobu chewbacca
jo
jojo jubiki sorry jobu tupaki who it's
revealed is alpha joy in the alpha
universe evelyn discovered how to jump
from universe to universe and she also
pushed her daughter into doing this as
well unfortunately it fractured her mind
and alpha joy now lives in every
universe everywhere all at once
witnessing everything alpha joy realized
that nothing mattered and she put
everything onto a bagel which created a
black hole to destroy the entire
multiverse yikes now i love this idea
and howard bloom actually theorized that
the universe itself was shaped like a
bagel which is a nice nice little detail
bagel shapes litter the movie and even
in the opening shot of the film we see
the family singing karaoke in a circular
mirror with a glass in the center of it
after this switches we get the circular
fan with a circle in the middle a
circular light with an inner ring and
another circular mirror you might also
notice the googly eyes on the pillow
which becomes important later on
raymond's face is then reflected in the
mirror next to evelyn showing how they
are separate and foreshadowing out the
waymen existing in another universe
later on when evelyn and joy are in this
room the security camera feed switches
for a second and we see the circles of
the multiverse before raymond is taken
over by the alpha version of himself it
is then the laundromat itself which is
littered with these circular holes that
create the doors of the machines we're
even introduced to joy staring into the
black abyss of one of these as the
clothes spin around it foreshadowing her
arc throughout the whole movie at the
irs alfa raymond uses an umbrella with
donuts on it and we discover that evelyn
has several hobbies that she's trying to
claim as business expenses this idea of
her being multi-skilled is of course
reflected in the alternate life she
leads there's the circular mirror beside
deidre's desk and also the ring around
her necklace on the way there we pass a
twirling piece of sign and later on
learned that evelyn almost would have
become this person had there been a
slight change to things d'adriath the
irs also circles the receipts with black
rings and yep it's all connected now the
dialogue is extra sharp too with evelyn
saying she wonders how weymon would have
survived without her but we learned that
he would have become a successful
businessman had they never moved to
america together her goodbye to join the
opening is also shot in the same way as
it is at the end there's also lines
about her constantly being pulled away
while she's literally pulled away and i
could probably spend an hour talking
about all the connective tissue that
this film has you have a lot on your
mind but i cannot imagine anything
mattering more
than the
conversation we are now having
concerning your tax liability
but nothing could possibly matter more
than this conversation we're having
right now concerning the fate of every
single world of our infinite multiverse
although we've spent the opening of this
video just talking about the details and
imagery that's used throughout what the
film also excels at is its overall
message and character development this
is very much a story about families
explored through the multiverse evelyn
is constantly distracted with her
business trying to be a good but strict
parent and also how she feels she failed
her father she can't keep her focus on
anything and thematically this is shown
through the film by her constant reality
jumping evelyn's mind is always
somewhere else and even when the irs
conversation is happening early on she's
distracted by the conversation with alfa
raymond the ending comes full circle
from this moment and we once more
catcher in the office being distracted
by the idea of the multiverse however
she grounds herself and makes sure that
she's present in the moment enjoying all
the highs and lows that life offers as
many of you know i've just had twins and
even though i love spending time with
them i have to admit i can often get
distracted by my phone and working on
the channel this is very much my
alternate life that takes me away from
being present in the moment but movies
like this remind us to keep our focus on
what's really important now not only is
this a journey for evelyn but it's also
one for her daughter joy though i told
that she's traveling through every
universe to kill all the evelines that
she comes across by the midpoint of the
movie we discover the truth alpha joy
actually wants to find a version of her
mother that can travel through the
multiverse to the level that she can
finally she'll have some common ground
with her and very much gain the mother
that she was unable to have in all of
the universes where she was pushed out
of her life she just wants someone who
can understand the emptiness within her
and also emphasize with what it's like
living a life where she's unable to find
a true connection we are told by alpha
joy that she put everything onto a bagel
but when she's listing off the contents
of this she states when i put everything
on a bagel
all my hopes and dreams my
old report cards
every breed of dog every last personal
ad on craigslist now the opening of
these items pulled from her life and it
very much represents the hopes and
dreams that she had but was forced out
of having to evelyn pushing her down the
path that she wanted for her the black
hole very much represents the pain
within her and thus it's become an
all-consuming void that will destroy all
meaning in the multiverse the film
culminates with joy wishing to travel
into this a metaphor for her becoming
lost forever in the nihilism of what she
feels inside evelyn however realizes
that she also has the ability to make
everyone happy and all those that have
tormented her throughout the film become
people that she transforms by using
their innermost desires to change the
way they see things this is something
that she herself has experienced in some
ways upon gaining the abilities of the
jobu tupac she almost lost her way
giving into the feeling of meaningless
that she discovered however weymond
pulled her back and she realized that
she loved him in every universe yes
that's a doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness reference and also
isn't it weird how both the main
characters in that movie also get eyes
on their foreheads but i digress now
weyman constantly talks about
unconditional kindness and throughout
the movie he demonstrates this at
several points as the complaining
customer that he dances with at the
laundromat whilst evelyn is distracted
and of course his speech about being
kind though evelyn looked down on him
and thought that he was naive now she
sees that he's someone who will be there
through it all even though there's a
universe where he went off on his own to
become a success he still came back to
her there's also the universe where
she's in love with theatre showing that
even though she's an enemy of could
potentially be the best thing that ever
happened to her if she alters her
perspective wayman shows her
unconditional love throughout every
universe and this shows evelyn that
empathy is the best way to finding a
connection this is why her style of
fighting changes for the final battle
and she instead employs love and
kindness to help who she can it's the
same strategy she uses on joy and in the
car park evelyn finally sees things from
her point of view and she understands
she has to at least give her the chance
to leave should she wish to now this is
shown by her traveling away her rock
falling off the cliff and also her going
into the bagel finally she's allowed her
daughter to stand on her own two feet
however she also asks the same
understanding from joy throughout every
possibility they've managed to become
every version of themselves but they
haven't been able to put themselves in
the other person's shoes finally at this
moment they do and both realize that
they could be anything anywhere but
they'd rather be with each other in that
moment there all they really have is
each other and now they could run away
and escape this it's where everything is
truly all together and they are with
each other even the movie star evelyn
who's known nothing but success and
admiration would rather work in a
laundromat if it means she gets to have
wayman as her husband and joy as her
daughter i'm not crying i'm not crying
i'm sorry
[Music]
now evelyn almost let joy go but the
pair both reveal that in all the endless
possibilities that they'd rather be
together finally the family is as one
and whereas in the opening we had evelyn
around the table on her own here the
family all surround her another thing i
noticed was there's now four sets of
googly eyes we have the ones above the
coat hangers on the left two just above
the security feed and also one over
joy's shoulder clearly this represents
the family and whereas in the beginning
there was one they are now all together
life is complete for them and rather
than all living in feelings of
disappointment they've started this new
year with each other accepting things
the way they are and making the best of
it evelyn and wayman share a kiss for
the first time in a long time and
finally there's a feeling of contentness
to the entire movie and it shows the
journey that she's gone on throughout
every universe evelyn has experienced
other things but here in this moment she
knows she truly belongs the movie very
much carries the message of making the
best of a bad situation and though
there's the feeling that nothing matters
if something matters then everything
matters i think now this is why i love
the film because on top of all the cool
effects and references there's a heart
to it that isn't really matched in most
of the movies beyond its story though
the film also excels in other areas like
its editing score and also the action
there's so many new and creative things
that they do in this film and it's
constantly awash with so many aspects
that haven't really been used all that
much in film even aspects like the
aspect ratio constantly switching gives
this feeling over the worldiness and i
love how you can often forget that most
of this is taking place inside the irs
building there's so much going on with
the film and even after discussing all
of this i feel like i'm just scratching
the surface there's a lot of complexity
here but also simplicity at the core of
it and overall this film is about family
it's fast and furious but also heavily
layered with amazing acting a career
defining performance by michelle yeo and
also kerehu kwan he's been massively
overlooked in hollywood and after his
appearance in temple of doom and the
goonies he was pretty much cast to the
side however he's come back with an
incredible performance that very much
grounds the film and it brings in the
outstanding visuals to lace it with a
feeling of humanity the movie excels at
everything it attempts to do and i'll be
shocked if it doesn't sweep the oscars
next year for me it has the best editing
best cinematography best directing best
original screenplay the lot this is an
incredible film and it's easy to score
at a perfect 10 out of 10. i'd of course
love to hear your thoughts so make sure
you comment below and let me know we are
in a competition right now giving away
three copies of the batman on the 15th
of june and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the movie we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so if that's
you then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers if you want something else
multiverse related to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of
doctor strange 2 which will be linked on
screen right now we went over the whole
film from top to bottom and it's
definitely worth checking out if you
enjoyed that movie and just want to talk
about more multiverse stuff if not then
thanks for sending through the video
i've been poor i'll see you in the next
one take care peace